hey what's up guys my name is a Cherno
and welcome back to my c++ series so
today let's get our tools set up so in
order for us to write programs in C++ we
need to have a computer and then a set
of tools that will let us build Sybil's
klas programs these tools of course are
going to depend on which operating
system you're using so this video is
going to cover Windows but if you're
using Mac or Linux then just click on
the screen and you'll be taken to those
videos because I made them as well
alright so Windows excellent choice
because Windows is the most widely used
operating system in the games industry
now to write C++ code all you really
need is just some kind of text editor
like notepad for example will do fine
however once you've written that code in
C++ as a text file we need to take that
and pass it through a compiler to
generate some kind of executable binary
so that we can run our program so what
we need at the very minimum is a
compiler that will take that text that
we've written and convert it into a
program however we can do a lot better
than that writing surface plus isn't the
easiest task and if you're using
something like notepad it's really just
gonna not help you at all so what you
can do instead is actually get a
development environment something called
an integrated development environment
this is basically a set of tools that
helps you write and debug your code in
our case since we're on Windows we're
gonna be using something called
Microsoft Visual Studio which is pretty
much the best idea out there now don't
get me wrong it's far from perfect but
it is the best thing that we've got I've
used a lot of different IDs and it's by
far my favorite Visual Studio has
plugins that will help you target pretty
much any platform like PC mobile
consoles everything which is why it's
the most popular idea in the games
industry so without further ado let's go
ahead and install that all right so here
we have Windows 10 doesn't really matter
what version of Windows you're using
we're gonna basically head on over to
Visual Studio comm link will be in the
description if you don't want to type
that out we're gonna click on download
Visual Studio and we're gonna get
community 2017 now Visual Studio
community is absolutely free and once
it's downloaded we're gonna want to
install that and installing Visual
Studio will take a significant amount of
time so you might want to come back now
this is Visual Studio 2017 which is
quite a bit better than 2015 it's a lot
faster and it has some pretty nice new
features and it's also going to be the
idea that we use for the entirety of
this series
now while this is happening I want to
quickly mention that there is actually a
plug-in called vigil assist which I use
just all the time I haven't used Visual
Studio without visual assist for
probably the last two years it's amazing
now it does cost money it's like I think
it's $99 yeah
99 dollars for a personal license but if
you do write a lot of code in Visual
Studio I highly recommend it it's
amazing it basically just gives you a
lot of features the Visual Studio is
missing and I mean they're not paying me
to say that I genuinely love visual
assist so yeah alright so visual studio
taking this time as usual now in terms
of what components we want Visual Studio
2017 has this brand new install that has
like a lot of things way more than 2015
the gist of what we really want is the
easiest way to go through this is just
to pick desktop development with C++
that includes pretty much everything you
need we don't need Univ Universal
Windows platform development that's
actually that's something called uwp
which is actually something entirely
different
net is something that you probably want
and still if you're using stuff like say
sharp I'm actually going to be using
that so I might install that but all you
really need to follow along with this
series is gonna be say plus plus desktop
development with say plus Paul's and you
don't actually need everything that's
included in here like this has stuff
like tables sofas a make an ATL support
I'm we don't really need that but the
easiest way again to install this is
just to click on desktop development
with C++ and be done with it so we'll
hit install and now it's gonna start
downloading and installing everything we
need so this will really take a while
all right so now the visual studio is
installed let's go ahead and launch it
you can either click launch where you
can you know get rid of this and then
click launch it's up to you so visual
studio open you're gonna want to
probably login with your account this is
just any Microsoft account ok and here
we see the start page so things that I
like to get done out of the box I like
to customize my settings and stuff like
that for example under tools options you
can go and change to dark mode for
example I quite like dark mode there's a
color theme you can just go ahead and
change that to dark because it's
actually already loaded my settings just
from the cloud and everything now I've
set up visual studio the way that I like
to use it including like the syntax
highlighting theme and everything like
if you guys want to use the same
settings as me you can just go ahead and
go to the channel home for such vs the
link will be in the in the description
and you'll download this vs settings
file once you've downloaded that file
you're gonna want to put it into
documents Visual Studio 2017 settings
and then just paste it in there and then
back in Visual Studio you can go tools
import and export settings import
selected environment settings hit next
just import new settings don't worry
about exporting your old one since it's
a fresh install turn OBS is the one you
want to use and then of course setup any
setting or all of them is really what
you want under general settings it
hasn't done everything but I mean the
default option is usually pretty good
just hit finish and everything should
work now if you don't have visual assist
installed you we might get some warnings
I have an actually install visual assist
I might install and then you know rerun
this thing but anyway if you hit close
everything should be set up the way that
I like it now so let's just make sure
everything works by creating a new
solution you can actually click on
there's a bunch of proto templates I'm
not sure the visuals to 2017 has changed
a bit but basically we're gonna go file
new project and then under visual C++
under general they'll be a template
called empty project we're gonna select
that put it any way you like I recommend
that you put it into C dev I've actually
made a folder for it inside C Devin and
CPP series the reason I don't like
having it here because first of all this
path is huge
second of all you'll see in my case this
path actually has a space in it which
will cause problems with some plugins
for example some components of Nvidia's
Android plugins for visual studio
actually just won't work if your path
has a space in it so that's already bad
news
also this puts it in your users
directory which isn't really necessary
so I like to have it just literally see
dev and then whatever my project is so
in this case EBP series that's actually
what I'm gonna put it you can give it a
name I'll call this hello world we're
literally just gonna write a little
hello world application that will print
hello world to the console and test out
our entire tool chain
now you'll see there's also something
called a solution name Visual Studio has
solutions and projects think of a
solution as
like a group of projects that are
related to each other they can be
various project types basically a
solution is like your workbench and then
each project is essentially just a group
of files which compiled into some kind
of target binary whether that be a
library or an actual executable so that
looks pretty good to me I'm just gonna
hit OK and we should be taken into our
project all right now I like to have my
solution Explorer on the Left all we're
gonna do for now is right click on
source files hit add new item under c++
file we're just going to call it main
dot cpp hit add then I'm going to type
hash include iostream inter main and
then I'm gonna do st st DC out color
world s city and line I'm gonna type in
STD cin dot yet and then i'm gonna right
click on my project and hit build we'll
have our output window show up and make
sure that everything succeeded there you
can see that is generated a hello world
dot exe file which is an executable
binary for windows and now you can run
it either by going to this directory in
fact let's let's take a look at this
directory heylook hello world eh see so
we can either run it by just
double-clicking in here and you can see
there's our application color world and
if we press any key then well if we
press enter it will terminate all we can
run it by just clicking on local windows
debugger which will actually build and
run it so there you go and we're
actually debugging the code right now so
that's it we've got application running
we've written our first application in
c++ and we've verified that our tools
work properly if you guys had any
problems with this or something didn't
go according to plan
leave a comment below and we'll see if
we can help you out alright sweet so
Visual Studio is installed and we're
ready to go and learn some c++ over the
next few videos we're gonna learn how
c++ actually works knowing how the
applause boss actually works is pretty
much the biggest key to writing c++ code
properly make sure you follow me on
twitter and instagram and if you really
like this series you can support it on
patreon but until next time goodbye
warm